see that TV I'm gonna shatter it do it
on one try
come with me I think I don't have number
one wait there's a lefty one all right
yeah you're Lefty righty Lefty baseball
what
all right yeah I see the swing already
I like me a lot today
I'm going Grady I can't compete with
that I'm not I'm not doing all that it's
too much energy
oh my goodness I do need a little tiger
glove
oh my gosh it's slipping
come on Grady
back net right here I gotta get a glove
you don't got a glove you just use this
this dude
the trick
there it is let's get to it fellas get
in there good girl
you got four I like where I'm at
oh that's four
Off the Wall look you see it yeah it's
cool it's not any points though
unfortunately look you get points to be
going like the little circles
wings
[Music]
that was almost a bucket that was yellow
did that go in yeah that has to be five
at least four
let the real men golf
why is he good though like yeah I don't
know like it's good it's almost alarming
oh I get 10. that's crazy hit the back
for 10. can we get some defense
oh my God it looks like the magnet it's
a daddy shot AB I feel like we're we're
just one of the best classes in a while
top to bottom it's not just like a one
through ten it's like everyone's good
this is definitely probably one of the
more known classes yeah just because
it's like how far names travel nowadays
with social media we're kind of like the
social media area too Arrow too I'm
gonna start doing some tick tocks nope
some of those things like we're just
bored away from basketball
kind of a little Escape just to
watch funny videos and stuff like if you
make that like distract you away from
the main thing then
that's when it comes a problem what are
the odds when Grady comes back defense
yep no pressure bus pipes
you got 20. how could you bowl and golf
and who
jacket
and dog yeah
and take a charge baby we gotta work
together to be great yeah we got a lot
here okay
I'll tell you the real walk we lost
already
[Music]
we got to change something up make an
adjustment slow tiger film session
[Music]
bro why can't Jairus do that let me run
it back hold up
oh
that's the point too three points okay
they have to say that loud this is a
hard sport it's so difficult bro
basketball is way easier than this it
has to be some people just like to hit
golf balls to relieve stress like you
smack that you can just come here
and just hit the ball like all day well
that makes more mental issues no this is
a stress reliever bro but what if you're
bad
golly duh bro it's time to wrap it's
time to wrap it up
easy money